moi ce qui me frappe avec vous c'est que
plus vous êtes devenu une star plus vous
êtes resté incroyablement gentil proche
de vos rêves et ce qui est fou c'est que
en fait on vous croise dans la rue on
vous croise dans les loges vous prenez
des nouvelles vous demandez comment vous
allez est-ce que vous avez toujours été
naturellement moi je trouve ça
incroyable quand on vous voit sur scène
ce côté showman incroyable on se demande
comment vous faites et dans la vie vous
êtes d'un naturel d'une gentillesse
c'est quoi c'est l'éducation c'est moi
ça m'a toujours saisi de vous voilà
déjà merci mais c'est je sais pas ouais
l'éducation forcément
j'ai toujours été quelqu'un de
reconnaissance déjà et puis j'aime
profondément les gens avant même de
faire ce métier déjà je pense qu'on fait
ce métier parce qu'on aime les gens de
base on aime se produire sur scène pour
divertir moi c'est c'est ma seule
prétention c'est de vouloir divertir les
gens qui viennent me voir à faire en
sorte qu'il repartent avec des étoiles
dans les yeux après avant ça même je
sais plus jeunes que ce soit dans les
colos que ce soit
dans les repas de famille j'ai toujours
aimé réunir venez on fait un truc on
fait un spectacle ou j'ai toujours aimé
être avec des gens et quand je faisais
du foot à haut niveau chez les jeunes
j'aimais bien aussi l'esprit d'équipe
prendre la parole etc et donc ça c'est
aussi ça fait partie de mon éducation
aussi André Bouchard conseiller
financier
Jean-Pierre non justement tu parlais de
football tu aurais voulu être
footballeur professionnel et être
acclamé par des par un stade et
plusieurs stades même là tu es acclamé
mais toi tout seul qu'est-ce que tu
préfères être acclamé par un stade pour
jouer au foot ou être quand même par un
stade pour ta prestation de chansons
c'est de toi
mais comment je l'ai dit c'est marrant
que parce que beaucoup de de mes amis
footeux qui viennent me voir en concert
voilà la chance que tu as ce que
j'aimerais être à ta place je dis mais
tu rigoles toi ils sont 80 000 ils
disent 80 000 pour une ville c'est ça
pour 11 joueurs hésite toi ils sont 10
15 20 000 ils sont là que pour toi et
c'est vrai que moi je je changerai rien
le seul regret que je peux avoir c'est
mieux jusqu'où j'aurais pu aller à quel
niveau dans le foot si j'avais continué
au-delà de mes 17 ans quand je suis allé
faire popstar mais j'ai absolument pas
de regret parce que aujourd'hui je suis
en équipe de France
tu sais pourquoi c'est pas passé au
niveau du passé parce que j'étais pas
prêt sur laisser quand ce dent était
venu me chercher à l'époque pour faire
un essai c'était pendant les vacances de
Pâques et je m'étais pas entraîné depuis
10 jours avec mon club mon père m'avait
dit tu t'entraînes avec ta mère parce
que j'étais parti dans un centre de
loisirs de vacances avec ma mère m'a dit
tu t'entraînes je dis ouais ouais je
suis pas évidemment pas aller
m'entraîner une seule fois je suis
arrivé j'étais à la rue physiquement par
rapport au mec qui était là depuis 15
jours ils avaient rien lâché et je le
savais mais juste pour finir 20 ans de
carrière et regarder les dates c'est que
des Zéniths et c'est que des stades et
ça c'est pas nombreux à faire ça il y a
plus de 25 Zénith il y a des il y a des
stades de foot surtout en ce moment
regarde
c'est pas tout le monde
bravo
la tournée les 20h oui j'ai une question
animalière
dans les rues Strasbourg rue du dôme
c'était déjà une énorme star je voulais
savoir ce que tu parles alsacien que
fait Tommy non pas mes parents sont pas
alsaciens du coup en fait c'était pas
c'est c'était pas à la maison je l'ai
jamais entendu en fait
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
mais je peux plus
je peux plus non mais sans déconner
là tu viens évidemment sur la promo de
de ton spectacle de ta tournée etc mais
moi je t'ai vu aussi sur scène au
théâtre est-ce que tu vas revenir aussi
au théâtre et ou peut-être dans un long
métrage ou oui alors évidemment c'est
c'est des projets qui m'ont donné envie
de continuer dans cette voie là au
théâtre j'ai beaucoup appris notamment
on m'a beaucoup appris et c'était une
superbe aventure maintenant ça moi la
priorité reste quoi qu'il arrive la
musique et ma famille et c'est vrai que
déjà de de trouver du temps pour les
deux c'est pas tous les jours facile
mais
la comédie on est en train de développer
des projets de fiction que je tournerai
plutôt sur le printemps 2024
en tout cas elle est extrêmement sérieux
une chose que personne ne sait c'est
qu'à l'époque il choisit bien toujours
ce qu'il fait que ce soit la fiction ou
les albums ou ces titres ou les singles
qui sortent à chaque fois je lui avais
proposé je sais pas tu te souviens de
faire section de recherche ah ouais
ouais je l'avais appelé je lui ai
proposé oui parce qu'on en parlait en
réunion excuse-moi tu es technique toi
c'est comme si j'ai attends Gilles tu
peux me gérer ça s'il te plaît
je l'aime beaucoup et je me suis dit non
mais perdu je vous explique si on peut
s'exprimer librement cette communauté
gélule Sénart et je m'y tiens tu lis les
scénarios
mais c'est un gars quoi
et donc oui je lisais je lisais le
scénario et je me suis dit ça c'est bon
ce serait génial si ma taxi
la productrice oui Dominique lancelotes
parce que il ne pouvait pas à ce
moment-là et qui me disait il m'a dit
franchement je me sens pas prêt encore
pour aborder la fiction à la comédie
c'est génial ça bosse le cerveau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un billet d'avion j'ai même pas
eu le temps de me changer le train
je suis arrivé comme ça
je voulais poser une question sur les
mains grillé ce con sur le foot
l'événement c'était que vous chantiez
devant la famille devant les enfants
qu'est-ce que ça fait de chanter devant
les enfants qui étaient là pour la
première fois je crois en plus
[Applaudissements]
c'est une très bonne question
il fallait évidemment que j'introduis
cette chanson que j'en parle et j'avais
peur de de complètement
parce que c'est une de mes chansons
préférées c'est quoi c'est avant vous
j'adore
et c'était la première fois en tout cas
que que les deux assistaient à un
spectacle et j'avais surtout un peu peur
de leur réaction moi et du coup ma femme
a filmé et voilà il était ils étaient un
peu frustré de pas pouvoir il disait je
vais aller voir papa mais ils étaient
ils sont pas endormis déjà c'est un
miracle ça veut dire qu'ils ont ils ont
une bonne question bravo Gilles
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu as déjà fait une demande à
une star internationale et ça n'a pas
abouti pour un feat et est-ce que tu
aurais justement avec qui faire un
ça
se passe déjà alors déjà vous avez pu
rendre compte je suis pas très vite dans
ma cave j'en ai pas fait énormément
auquel je pense tu vois c'est j'ai envie
de dire c'est plus nouvelle génération
ou culture urbaine de de faire plein de
fées moi j'aime déjà faire mes titres et
si je sens qu'il y a de la place pour
quelqu'un qui pourrait apporter quelque
chose
mais inter non j'ai pas envoyé de
réponse qui n'est pas
de question de proposition et je peux
insister est-ce qu'il y a un nom que
un artiste moi dont je suis fan Chris
Martin de colpa j'adore